[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today all right
let's go out to Birmingham Alabama and
talk to Phillip what's up
Phillip how's it going we're rocking on
to the breaking da brother what's up hey
man I just had a quick question so uh
well one thing to start off my wife and
I started uh doing the the snowball two
months ago we've already paid off
$35,000 in debt whoa
what' you sell did you sell
something no well I'm in sales and so uh
I had a big motivator to uh make some
extra money and I had my biggest month
ever and was able to uh pay off a lot of
debt really quickly congratulations man
that's fantastic what's up yeah all
right so um question my grandmother is
being taken advantage of financially by
my aunt a I'm wondering how I can step
in and help how how have you already
tried
so I I haven't tried yet okay I haven't
said anything to anybody and the
situation I'm about to share I'm not
even supposed to know but my mom told me
because it's one of those it's like an
emergency situation so um I'll give you
give you some context so my on the on
the back end my grandmother she
struggles financially didn't invest in
retirement didn't know who Dave Ramsey
was ever until I I started going into
him a while back and so unfortunately
she wasn't set up now she's in her 70s
has no retirement and she just draws
Social Security and I think she brings
in like 1400 a month so she's she's
she's she's okay she's not like very
thin yeah very thin yeah no margin there
so she came to me two or three years ago
about um how does
she um how do she get some breathing
room and so I I essentially bought her
house for what was owed on it and put
some money into it to fix it up and she
lives there for free she just pays
utilities and that was kind of a
retirement thing she and I worked out so
that gave her a little bit of margin but
you but your name's on your name's on
the house you own it correct okay
correct so um so anyway so she's been
fine for two or three years like not
rich but she's doing good well my my
aunt who is her daughter um is uh very
bad with money very very bad with money
and almost weekly it seems like is
asking my grandmother for money nothing
big it's usually 40 bucks here 50 bucks
there but that stuff add done especially
when it's coming from somebody with no
margin um so anyways it's always
bothered me I hadn't said anything it's
my grandmother's money whatever um but
recently uh last week I got a call from
my
mom um my my grandmother ended up paying
a a bill utility bill or something for
my aunt and my aunt apparently took a
picture of her debit
card and ended up using it for other
things as well without telling my
grandmother wow yeah and last month um
my grandmother is at Walmart checking
out getting groceries and cargs declined
which is one embarrassing but two it's a
it's one of those you're like oh my God
I know I have money in there and it's
not there what's going on that's
straight up illegal yeah it's stealing
yeah yeah so she goes and checks and uh
apparently about $500 has been spent um
without permission from my grandmother's
card um on an online game that my aunt
has been
playing um and so anyways grandmother
confronts the
aunt and the aunt goes oh I don't know
how that happened you know that's crazy
I'll try to get your money back that
whole thing and that's kind of where
we're at and I'm not supposed to know
about this because my grandmother knows
how I'm gonna you know react well here's
the deal here's the deal so this is one
of those situations not by your hand but
in your
lap you didn't ask for this situation
you didn't ask for somebody in your
family to be so deceitful as to steal
from an elderly mother wow and quite
honestly quite frankly you didn't ask
for your mom to not get involved with
her mother and her sister which is her
responsibility as you started talking my
first question to you was going to be
call your mom or why haven't you called
your mom and your mom has passed the
buck to
you and so yeah I would if I'm you I
would tell my mom mom you have 24 hours
to get involved and then I'm going to
get involved you've given me this
information and I can't sleep at night
I'm the homeowner I've already bailed
this whole family out of problem one and
I'm about to go get involved again too
and by the way I'm going to call the
police I was about to say mom's going to
get her credit her her debit card
changed she she needs to do that before
the day is over because she did that
already okay good um but are you calling
the popos I'm call cuz that's what I'm
doing I'm calling the
police at the very minimum I'm making it
very clear to my to my aunt because
nobody else in the family will if you
come near grandmother again and ask for
money I call the police cuz you stole
this right and yeah I understand that
this is awkward and weird
unfortunately your mom put you in a very
awkward weird situation unfortunately
your family has not been as responsible
with money as you have been and they
have put you in multiple awkward weird
positions and if people keep doing that
to me I'm going to take the straightest
path
out and by the way okay grandmother can
do what grandmother wants to do as much
as that pains me to say so if she says I
want you to butt out you are not calling
the police get away from me I don't want
that's going to hurt it's going to hurt
like all bloody hell and she gets to do
that because she's a grown up and that's
her
money yeah
right yeah why did your mom not make a
whole bunch of calls and ring all the
bells if I found out my little brother
was stealing from my mom oh it's going
down oh my gosh he would never a million
years do that he's such a person of high
integrity why didn't your mom get on the
phone with your her sister
immediately well she she said something
to her or or sorry she wanted to say
something but my grandmother goes hey
I'm telling you this I shouldn't have
told you don't say anything to your
sister don't say anything to anybody
well then don't tell me my mom is
exactly my mom calls me I'm the
responsible one of the family when I
speak people in the family listen
because they're like you know like he
means what he says he says what he he
means you know all that stuff good for
you for for breaking this family curse I
I I would tell my mom you've got 24
hours to get right in the middle of this
cuz I'm going to and she'll say oh
Philip don't do that please grandmother
told me in confidence grandmother wants
someone to help or she wouldn't have
said anything yeah that's what I'm
thinking and she's thinking I told my
daughter and nobody's helping well she's
hoping there's a way this could be done
where no one's feelings get hurt and no
one has to know about it and that that
you can just sweep it under the rug but
that's you're so far like that it's just
not possible POS no at this point yeah
yeah I'd put everybody on notice and
here's the other thing you're sending a
message one of two messages number one
if you don't want me involved you better
not tell me because I'm getting involved
number two um I don't play this game we
treat each other with dignity and
respect we don't steal from family
members we don't steal from our elderly
mothers wow we don't we don't commit
fraud in our own house I won't stand for
that and
there we go at the end of the day also
this might even be a little bit
weirder that's your home you can tell
your aunt you are not welcome in my
home right yeah you could tell your aunt
I'll no trespass you on my property
because grandmother's a tentant tenant
of my
place but not
welcome oh it was an accident I didn't
mean to it was an accident that's not an
accident she got caught yeah she was
trying to make some money on an online
game
and wouldn't you know it she didn't win
man golly